now May 9th is a significant date in
Russia's military calendar Victory Day
celebrates the Soviet defeat of the
Nazis in World War II traditionally it's
marked by bombastic and patriotic
military parades in Moscow this year the
focus is likely to be on the parade to
deflect attention from Russia's sluggish
campaign in Ukraine rehearsals in Moscow
are already underway
if you stroll around moscow's tourist
District among the stereotypical Russian
souvenirs you can now find the letter
Zed printed everywhere
it's merchandise in support of Russia's
quote special military operation
The Only Name allowed for the war in
Ukraine
in the city center tanks and rocket
launchers roll towards the Kremlin while
Russian soldiers fight on the front line
in Ukraine
it's a rehearsal for the May the 9th
Victory Day Parade which for many is an
annual spectacle
but this year everything is different
this is indeed a holiday
no but it's one with tears in the eyes
because now is the time to think about
the irretrievable losses that have been
suffered
I love my country very much
I'm not ashamed to be Russian
I like our president very much because
he protects us
I don't want to offend anyone
but Putin is a president for the world I
love him
the parade is also a grand show of
patriotism
no one here dare criticize what is
happening in Ukraine right now
no comment I support my country that's
all I can say
the parade which celebrates a victory
over Nazi Germany will be smaller this
year fewer soldiers only around 11 000
and fewer special effects but Vladimir
Putin could use the day to mobilize more
troops
as Moscow gets dressed up for its big
day this will be a 9th of May like no
other
well May 9th is always a big day for
Russia but what message is Moscow likely
to deliver this year a formal
declaration of war a national
mobilization of reservists or even the
end of fighting in Ukraine Russia's
President Vladimir Putin is due to give
a speech on Monday which could have a
significant impact on the developments
in this war let's bring in DW's head of
fact checking here Joshua Viber Joshua
you and your team are tracking and
debunking War propaganda coming from the
Kremlin based on that what kind of
announcement are you expecting on May
9th
very good question Terry
um there is a lot of speculation about
this day and about the Russians tragedy
more broadly based on recent propaganda
claims he made and military operations
in Ukraine it's likely that President
Putin will use the kremlin's victory in
Mario poll and the territorial gains in
eastern Ukraine As proved that this
tragedy succeeded and we expect him to
unite Russians behind the goal of
completely yeah liberating the donbus
and luhansk regions that would mean the
war would continue
now one reason given by President
poutine for a so-called special military
operation Ukraine was the need to in his
terms denotsify the country what are we
to make of that claim
um Putin uses the term demensification
which refers to the Allies policy for
Nazi Germany after World War II but
obviously you can't compare Nazi Germany
with Democratic or crane President
Vladimir silenski is a russian-speaking
Jew we all know that which is not
something that would be possible in the
Nazi State and let's look at the last
parliamentary elections in 2019 in
Ukraine when a united front of all
radical right-wing parties won just two
percent of the vote Democratic parties
have been dominating the country's
political landscape for years now and
even if there were some truth or is some
truth about that there were some right
uh groups or elements in the famous as
of regiment that would not prove this
claim there is simply no evidence for
broader Nazi problem with the Ukrainian
society and all this is why 300
international historians published a
statement that says the denizification
claim by Russia is factually wrong
important points there another Russian
narrative is that its war of aggression
is actually an act of self-defense by
Russia is there any truth to this claim
Yoshi
well this claim is observed because
everyone knows that Russia started this
war by launching a full-scale invasion
of a crane on February 24. there are
pictures videos satellite images which
prove this so no doubt about this fact
but why do Russians still believe that
this aggression is an elect Act of
self-defense well because of Russia's
efficient propaganda campaign and that
that happened via television radio and
social media President Putin even
claimed that this military operation is
in accordance with article 51 of the
United Nations Charter which allows for
self-defense measures that's wrong for
several reasons first the two Breakaway
regions Donetsk and luhansk which Putin
wants to defend are not recognized as
States under international law second
there's absolutely no evidence for an
alleged genocide of the russian-speaking
population there and third the massive
use of force against insulation screw
out Ukraine is this disproportionate
question is now Terry if you have a
build a lie that big what is your exit
strategy Putin must win this war that is
the Trap of the [ __ ] kremlin's own
propaganda now and so this could mean
that whatever happens on May 9 it will
likely not end Putin's war in Ukraine
Joshua thank you very much for your fact
checking for your insights that was
Joshua Weber head of DW's fact checking
team
spring and Sam cranny here Sam cranny
Evans he's an analyst at the Royal
United Services Institute that's a
london-based defense and security Think
Tank thanks for being with us Sam how
important is foreign intelligence for
the Ukrainian Army
well it it serves two purposes the first
is it it has this political message it's
morale boosting message that the
ukrainians aren't alone and that there
are you know powerful states willing to
back them to quite a a significant
extent by providing that intelligence
and that would have to come from
National Assets so it will be U.S
aircraft and satellites and and NATO
aircraft and satellites providing that
kind of information
uh in a a military sense it forms part
of a picture so the Intelligence on its
own for instance the the mosque bar that
you just referenced that would have had
to have been paired up with Organic
real-time intelligence for the
ukrainians to be able to act on it so it
helps cue the ukrainians onto what might
be important or useful targets but the
ukrainians still have to do uh you know
a fair amount of work themselves
now Ukraine's Western partners are
stepping up their arms supplies as well
the German government now says it will
send howitzers to support the Ukrainian
Army what difference will this heavy
Weaponry make
well in the big picture Germany's agreed
to send seven self-propelled houses
which isn't going to make a huge
difference to the totality of Ukraine's
Battlefield uh they probably need you
know a few hundred howitzers and that
kind of thing again it provides that
important political message that
Ukraine's not on its own and that the
West is willing to support it in a
tactical sense how it says in general
and the provision of artillery is very
important for the current phase of the
war the evidence suggests that the
Russians are quite happy at the moment
to sit behind their long-range artillery
and just back to the Ukrainian forces
into submission to increase casualties
and losses upon the Ukrainian forces and
without additional Heavy Artillery to
replace Ukrainian losses to additionally
support new Ukrainian reserves that are
being developed the ukrainians can't
really fight back against that kind of
combat that kind of tactic so it's it's
important in the bigger picture but in
terms of the the German contribution to
do it you know it's just part of a wider
hole right yeah Germany has been
reluctant so far and it's just uh to
send heavy weapons to Ukraine but it's
now beginning to change its tomb but
there's a lot more heavy weapons going
into Ukraine from other countries
including the United States but just a
question about how effective those
weapons can be for Ukrainian forces to
defend their territories in the south
and east of the country given how long
it might take to get those that heavy
equipment there and the need for
training
yeah I Western systems do introduce a
training burden that will be new to the
ukrainians and they also introduce the
logistics and Supply burden that will be
new to them so they won't have domestic
structures set up to take care of them
but Western forces are providing a lot
of support they're providing a lot of
training that will enable the ukrainians
to get these systems into service quite
quickly the important thing to bear in
mind is we don't really know where we
are in this war so we might be right at
the beginning we might be close to the
end we don't really know but the switch
to Native thing that can make it easier
for NATO countries to support them
certainly more so than the use of former
Soviet or or you know Ukrainian standard
systems
Sam thanks for talking with us that was
Sam crony Evans an analyst at the Royal
United Services Institute
thank you